hello everyone so I will talk about
solvability
of parliament systems
over finite field
so what's our problem we are given
a tuple of parlor Mills
say
F1 F2 through FM
over a finite field
so each
f i is an N variate polynomial
over a finite field let's say FP
yeah
very soon I will fix P to be a prime
and we are given the finite field and
this Tuple of Parliament
and we we are concerned about the
variety
of this defined by this
so I will refer to this as the geometric
variety the set of all points in the
algebraic closure of FP
so that
all F I's vanish
at the point I at the point a
H but in this talk I will mostly be
concerned with the rational points on
this variety which is
all points in the base field f p itself
and ideally given this bunch of
polynomials I want to be able to answer
questions about the set of rational
points on this variety efficiently so
what are the questions that one can ask
the first is the solubility which is the
the main topic of this talk
if
if the set of rational points non-empty
one can ask to find Solutions
which is
ah
find a point
find the rational point on this variety
and one could also ask for the counting
question
what is the
size of this set of rational points
and will mostly be concerned about this
question
whether the right whether the set of
rational points is not empty but along
the way I will
tell you things about these two
questions also
um
so let me
just make a few remarks about the input
size and the input representation how
are the polynomials given to me so ah
so I will I want to talk about
algorithms for these questions and their
complexities I have to tell you about
the representation of the inputs so each
polynomial will be given to me as a
vector of coefficients so I have M
polynomial
each of them
is of degree D on N variables so if you
just represent it by the knife
as a list list of coefficients you'll
have so many coefficients
and
each such coefficient is a element of
the finite field so you can represent it
using log P bits so this is the size of
the input that we have
and ideally we would like to answer all
these three questions in time polynomial
in the input size which is which is this
right
of course this is a canonical NP
complete problem
we cannot hope to solve it efficiently
all these three questions are NP hard
so uh so
before ah
before I go on to the exact results here
let me just mention
that there's a trivial algorithm for
which will answer all these three
questions
which is the following since we are
concerned only about the rational points
we could try all possible points
there are P to the N of them
so there's a trivial algorithm with this
much running time which solves all these
three questions and ah
so so sort of this will be the Benchmark
we will we want to be really efficient
in terms of this
compared to this
Okay so
so the theorem that I want to
that will gradually build up to is the
following
if you fix the dimensionality of
this problem
so
for any fixed
end
there is a
polyester time algorithm
foreign
ability
so let me just make a few remarks about
uh
so about this theorem statement here
first of all I have hidden the
dependence on N here
the dependence on N currently that I
know is rather bad it's D to the 2 to
the n
times F
but I suspect
that this can be improved I strongly
suspect this can be improved to D to the
N the analysis here is probably sloppy
the second thing is this
Builds on a series of results starting
from the work of Burley camp in the 60s
so ah
so I'll present all those ideas to you
um
and one can ask for similar questions
similar algorithms for questions two and
three
uh
now this algorithm here is a
deterministic algorithm
if you
are looking for a rational point on this
variety
we know of a randomized polynomial time
algorithm for fixed end
for doing this
and Counting the number of rational
points is
difficult in almost all cases all cases
where n is more than two there are a
very few situations in which we can
count the number of rational points and
that is a major area of research in
algorithmic number Theory whether you
can count even the number of rational
points on curves over finite fields or
not
so
before you go on so of course the
trivial algorithm is polynomial and S so
so P must not appear in this somehow
uh yeah
it's the logarithm but then it doesn't
occur explicitly otherwise an impulse
and that yeah so here we will have
running time which is polynomial in D M
and log p
T is the degrees right
is the degree of the milk yes
each fi is of degree
at most d
yeah can you replace C plus and choose n
by the number of terms
number of no the by the sparsity of
these no I don't know how to do that
in fact there's some very recent work of
chi chang which seems to do something
about it but in general dealing with
sparse polynomials is much more
difficult
so throughout the rest of the stock
so I'll think of n as fixed so it will
be good
for I mean for
uh
say n is three
it will be just easier to follow this
and ah
for ease of presentation
I will assume that P is prime most of
what I say will hold over any finite
field but it will just help me with the
exposition to assume P Prime I won't
have to deal with some degenerate cases
and I will mention some open problems
which are open really when p is Prime
and solutions are known over small
characteristic fields
and
and also just to sort of
tell you that we want to avoid this
regime where the trivial algorithm works
you should think of TF large
this is the main thing that we are
concerned with so think of PS Maybe
at least two to the D or something so
so in that kind of situation the trivial
algorithm is very slow
so any questions about the problem
statement or the
theorem statement
before I go on
question yeah so you could I suppose in
this range when p is large you could
also ask an approximation question
version of questions yes it turns out
that you can also answer the
approximately the number of solutions
here and deterministically so this has
an approximation algorithm and it will
just follow from what I tell you
uh okay so
here will be the outline of this stock
I will try to keep this outline here
so ah
the way I plan to present this is to
gradually build it up I will start with
the case where
n is equal to 1
then
go on to n equal to 2 which will contain
most of the ideas anyway and then
okay
see that how to generalize it to n equal
to 3 and Beyond
and within
uh
each N I will first reduce the problem
to to varieties defined by a single
polynomial so
in some sense to varieties which are
correspond to hypersurfaces
and then we'll see how to handle the m
equal to one case in all of these
so the
so let's go on
to our first
case n equals one
yeah please feel free to stop me and ask
questions
so now we are given
each f i
is a uni varied polynomial in X1
and
we want to know whether they have a
common solution or not so the first
thing I'll do is reduce it to the case
where m is equal to 1 and in this case
it's very easy
suppose if we look at the gcd of
all the FIS
this can be computed efficiently
by Euclid's algorithm
and
and then the main point is that
the rational points of this variety
are
contained in the rational points
of the gcd
effect
right
so
so now we are
we have reduced our problem to a single
univariate polynomial
and how to do
how to check whether it has a root or
not
so now suppose if we look at the gcd
of G
with
x to the P minus X
so
now recall that
over a finite field
x to the P minus X it factors completely
and the roots are all the
points in the finite field
so this
the roots of H will exactly be the
rational points on G
and now the the only non-trivial thing
here is how to compute this gcd
and I claim that this gcd can be
computed efficiently the main point here
is that this is a very large degree
polynomial so it is not
immediately obvious how to do this
so so basically we want to run Euclid's
algorithm for computing gcd
but
in the first step of the Euclid's
algorithm recall that you will divide
this polynomial by this
so you will get some remainder
and then you take the gcd of the
remainder with G and so on
and
the the main observation here is that
this first step of the Euclid's
algorithm well you want to compute this
remainder can be done efficiently and
the way to do it is by repeated squaring
so you start with X1 compute X1 Square x
1 to the 4 x 1 to the eight and so on
and multiply an appropriate
subset of them together to compute X1 to
the P mod G
and and in this entire process
our degrees never go more above the
degree of G so the degree of all our
univariate polynomials stay below D and
that's why this is efficient
yes
yeah so it's a small modification of
Euclid cell God
so the proposition is that h x 1 can be
computed efficient
and we we have a name for this we call
it repeated squaring
and this is uh
from the 60s
we already knew knew it
okay
so in fact
not only does it help so now
if I just look at
the degree of H
this is exactly
the number of rational points
on my variety so I compute the gcd and
look at the degree and I've solved
questions one and three both of them
in this case
and everything is efficient here
now uh
although this is somewhat away from the
main topic of this talk I can't
help you give an idea of how to solve
question two also in this case and
this is uh
this is work due to Burley camp
Alvin birthday Camp who was here in
Berkeley and due to canter and
rosenhurst
so so now we want to find the roots of H
also
right so
the question is
foreign
these are the roots of H
alpha 1 Alpha two
through Alpha e
so I'm going to try to factor h
and keep on factoring until I hit a root
so
here's one neat observation
how do I factor ah
so ah
suppose it happened
that some of the roots of H were
quadratic residues and some were not
residuous
in particular let us say
alpha 1 was a residue
so recall that residues are in a finite
field are all sort of the squares
a number is a residue if there exists a
beta such that beta square is Alpha and
also ah a number is a residue if and
only if the P minus 1 by 2 8 power is 1
so if it so happened that
one of
uh among the pair alpha 1 and Alpha two
one of them was a residue and the other
was not a was a non-residue
then
if you were to compute
H hat which is the gcd
of H
with
with the polynomial was
roots are all the residues in the field
X to the P minus 1 over 2 minus one
then
H hat
will be a non-trivial factor of f of H
so it's non-trivial in the sense that
it's not equal to 1 or h
so
so just to summarize
uh
if it so happened that
some of the roots were residues and
others are not then we obtain a
non-trivial factorization of
h
so now how to
uh
how do we handle the case where
all the alphas are residues or all the
alphas are non-residuous
and here's the idea it's a very simple
one but a very beautiful one
do a random shift
so let me explain this
so suppose if I take h x h of x
and
shifted by a randomly chosen
elements from the finite field
so pick a beta at random from the finite
field
and consider this polynomial call it h
tilde of X One
okay
so its roots are essentially just the
alpha is shifted by the betas
okay
now the claim here is
that
for now since this is H tilde is
obtained from H by this simple shifting
in particular the factors of H tilde are
in one one correspondence with the
factors of H just by shifting
so it so factoring H is equivalent to
factoring H tilde we know R beta we have
ourselves chosen it
and
the the claim is that with good
probability H still satisfies this
condition
so with good probability I can Factor H
tilde
and thereby Factor H itself so
with
probability about half
yeah okay
yeah some
flame which is about half
foreign
Ty half
for the shifted Parliament one of these
new Roots will be a residue and the
other non residue or vice versa
so with probability about half I can
Factor this and then I just keep keep on
doing this and if one beta fails I just
pick try a few more beta and with very
high probability very quickly you will
be able to factor h
so let me just prove this
so the proof is also very simple
so
this is equivalent to saying that I want
the difference to be non-zero
so for the object on the left hand side
think of it as a polynomial
it's a non-zero polynomial in beta
because for example if you plug in beta
equal to Alpha One
this is a non-zero number
and it's a
polynomial in beta of degree at most T
by 2 roughly P minus 1 by 2 let's say p
by 2.
so it has at most
p over 2 zeros
so so
and I've picked beta randomly from FP so
there are P choices of beta and
with problem and roughly half of them
are back so with with probability that
we have
this will be non-zero
foreign
so yeah
this is a very simple and beautiful idea
it has been around for
30 maybe almost 40 years now
we don't know how to de-randomize this
so this is open
find the deterministic
polytime algorithm
for computing rules
yeah so that's all that I want to say
about the Cape Fear n is equal to one
any questions
I should get is there any Improvement to
the probability like you get probability
three-fourths yeah there is there are
some improvements to the probability so
here I just use the facts
uh I just used two of the rooms Alpha
400 and Alpha 2.
when you have more Roots you can do a
better analysis and the probability here
becomes substantially less depending on
how many roots you have
so in this univariable case it's places
to take the input sized number of terms
and that would still be the problem what
you've just described right no so when
we want to do this gcd computation here
so in that case the first step of the
gcd computation is
divide this by H and compute the
remainder so although H might be sparse
this remainder might be very dense and
then and then
yeah to improve the probability you
could just
um increase the running time by a
constant factor and do it several times
yeah
um you could get it to three-fourths
just by doing it twice yes exactly
yeah so you can improve the probability
by Distributing it let's say if you
repeat it the long period times then or
most certainly you will have
Facebook
so let's now go on to the byway case we
have a bunch of milk
airplane so for the exposition of the
five widget case it will help me
my variables have X and Y rather than X1
and X2
it will be easier to present thing
um
last two points and like before the
first thing one does is
taking the gcds of all the pairs
so suppose
you take the gcd of F1 and F
call it g g of X by
and suppose the gcd is non-trivial it's
different from one
then notice this
that
our set decomposes into a union of two
smaller things
so let's say
F1 is
G times F1 hat
and F2 is a times F2 hat
then the zeros of F1 and F2
decomposers
zeroth of G
Union the G zeros of F1 hat and F2
and more generally even if you throw in
all the other polynomials
we also obtain a decomposition
so
so we just let's
keep on taking care by gcds and
breaking our problem into two sub
smaller sub problems until we can't do
it anymore
so after the end of this
assume that
we advise our pairwise
oh uh essentially just run Euclid's
algorithm but now in one way yeah in one
variable
right is that really what you do you
just see the gcd inspect one variable or
this is a random choices of choice of uh
changing variables or something yeah so
there are some degenerate cases so what
is referring uh
yeah but I know that descended
there's a random shift you can do to
take care of it
open
and so this doesn't introduce a factor
of 2 to the m
study this doesn't introduce an X I mean
you have to do every every pair and then
thank you join keep going yeah it
doesn't do too many
because the degrees are going down and
if you look at the sum of the degrees
you you wouldn't have changed too much
okay
so so now suppose
MS
so
or more then one thing one can do is
let's look at the first polynomial I
could take the resultant
with respect to say x let's call it y
Ro y this is a univated polynomial in
right and since they are Co Prime this
will be non-zero
so now
any common zero of F1 and F2
okay so one more thing
for
it will be easier for me to tell you
about the randomized algorithm first so
initially I will assume the use of
Randomness and then later we'll see how
to be randomly
so here's where the use of Randomness
comes in
because so here's an elementary
proposition
now
for any common zero of F1 and F2 the y
coordinate must be a zero of the
resultant
so if
the point a b belongs to the radius then
T must be at 0
so by that algorithm that I told you the
randomized have gotten you find all its
roots there are only roughly d square
many of them
for each of those roots
plug that back into
the F5
and I have gotten the system of
polynomials in one variable
and then and then we know how to solve
that
so
so that's it so so
if M was more than two
uh we know how to do it so now assume so
the randomization here you're doing some
random substitutions to put them in a
position
randomization we are using to find the
roots here yes I have to find the roots
okay
but also um you need to reduce the and
greater than two case to the N equals
one case I'm going to take the random
linear combination of polynomials right
take two randomly combinations uh no so
I could do it with just the first two of
them okay yeah but in practice that's a
better idea to take random linear
combination but
I can do it just with the first two
because their Co Prime this will be
nonsense
okay so uh
so here uh we'll use what are called
whale bounds so let me tell you the idea
behind wheel bounds
and this is where it will also answer
kiran's question it will in fact get an
approximation algorithm for Q3
so
uh
so let me tell you about where it goes
but before I give you the formal
statement of will bounce let me give you
some intuition
so suppose you ask this question
suppose
I pick a univated polynomial over FP at
random
of degree D let's say just a univated
polynomial and
suppose I am interested in how many
roots there are
so
here's
the question
I picked a univated polynomial at random
of degree d
over f c
and let's ask this question what's the
number of rules
of which
the expected number of rules
this is a finite set when you look at
degree D polynomial uniformly
so
the answer it has canceled is one almost
one one plus two over P but let's ignore
this uh two of the fish very small
anyway
so in expectation
a random polynomial random Universal
polynomial has just one root in the base
Cube does this number depend on the
measure I mean if you take
yeah yeah
further than for the uniform
distribution it is
so
no uh
I can
tell you about welcome
so suppose if I have a bivariate for
longer over FP now
so in Imagine doing this so
you have two variables
suppose if you run over all possible
choices of the Y variable all possible
values of Y in the field FB then
in expectation we expect we for each
choice of five we expect one zero to pop
out so
on F1 to be B
and
the whale counts tells you that this is
indeed the case
up to an error term
and
if
F1 satisfies some nice algebraic
conditions
so I'll tell you what that algebraic
condition is it most so most that binary
polymers will satisfy this Condition
it's called
absolute irreducibility so
suppose F1 is irreducible
and Alpha absolutely irrigation
then the number of rational points the
next one is roughly
so okay
so by is reducible here I mean
irreducible over FB and absolutely
reducible just means that it's
absolutely it's irreducible over
the algebraic closure
so let me
pick some examples to illustrate this
lotion
so for example suppose
square root of
minus 1 is not in FC then consider this
polynomial x square plus y Square this
will Factor over the closure like this
so so
this is
irreducible but not absolutely
electrical
on the other hand if you look at a
polynomial like this
this is always absolutely redist
foreign
there is also a Converse of this
statement which is true so not exactly
but there's a partial conversation
so
it's actually irresistible
foreign
but not
absolutely irreducible
then
all the rational points
of F1
their singularities of F1
fin in particular the number of rational
points can be at most d square
foreign
so I want to tell you now about the
the algorithmic use of this so
I've given a binary binary Parliament
so
suppose I factor it
into irreducible factors over ft
uh
then for each of these reducible factors
I check whether it is absolutely
reducible or not
add
if if there is some absolutely radical
Factor we know it has lots of zeros
otherwise
we look at the singularities so we have
and the singularities will be very small
and we have reduced our problem to a
lower dimensional problems
so
since this is going to be crucial for
the deterministic algorithm I want to
tell you how to factor polynomials this
is an algorithm due to calcium
foreign
I will sort of
do it in picture
it won't be
formally correct but you can
turn that automatic idea into a
algebraic formalism and it will work
so okay let's see
for Simplicity that we have a polynomial
which has two factors G1 and G2
so
if I were to
draw the zero set of
of f it will look like this it will be a
union of
two curves
say this curve is g 1 equal to zero
and
the other curve G two equal to 0.
and now
uh the first idea is
suppose
on this curve on the first curve
I could find a lot of points let's say
P1 P2
B
d square plus 1
suppose if I could find a bunch of
points on
all of them on the on the same cut out
of these two
okay one more thing let's assume that
we know the degree of G one
let's say it's e in practice we don't
know but we just guess it and we iterate
over all possible choices
so
uh okay so
we're degrading a total degree or
anything
uh
so now if I have a bunch of points on
the same curve I could interpolate
a polynomial Edge through those points
so I can
compute the binary polynomial which
Renditions on all these ones right and
let's say I interpolate the degree e
polynomial
through these points
and a non-critical solution exists and a
non-triguous polynomial like this
because we know that g one itself
is a solution to this
now
just observed by bezel theorem so we
have a polynomial of degree e
which vanishes
on
lots of which has lots of common zeros
with another irreducible polynomial of
degree
so H must in fact be just a scalar
multiple of zero
so to summarize if you have a bunch of
points on one of the components we can
find that component
and now
in practice we don't have
a bunch of points on the on the single
component so how do we do
obtain them
so
suppose I have one point on this
component
let's call it even one point I can
obtain the following way I could plug in
y equal to 0 and solve for x
at least with randomization I can do it
now start with this one point
take the tangent
to the curve at this point you can do
this given f
amount in the direction along the
tangent and you will have found another
Point P2 on the Curve
let's start with P2 draw the tangent
that we do go in infinite decimal amount
along the tangent you have another Point
P3 and so on
and that's it and now uh I sort of
waved my hands in the sense that I said
go and infinite decimal amount along the
tenant but if you
put it into an algebraic formalism it
turns out that this idea works
so this is called substance algorithm
for factory binary polymer
yeah
I can find the tangent just one of them
yeah so I'll leave it as an exercise
you look at the derivative effect
and the derivative will have two terms
uh
since you you have a point on one of the
things that the other term which is not
important will vanish
so definitely if you just work it out
look at the derivatives of this
evaluated as soon you'll see that engine
staring at you
some kind of neutral helps hence
yes yes
so the the technical love for term for
this is called Hensel lifting
but does this mean you go into a power
series one of the variables or do you go
over the addicts the power series
okay
so now all this if you think about it it
will combine the whale bounds with the
factoring algorithm we get a randomized
algorithm for
uh for this question
it's called our solubility question
and it also gives us a
randomized algorithm for for this the
second question finding a rational point
because we know that there are lots of
rational points on our curve you just
pick your X coordinated random and
solved for y so so you get this also
but counting the number of rational
points on curve remains a major open
question and we know how to do it on
only very few cases
I'm sorry there's a question
you may have answered this already but
how do you find a single root in this
so I take the intersection of the curve
with the x axis and then you use the
universe and then you say univariated
what if your polynomial is a product of
things with very few roots and you don't
find after plugging
y equal to zero so I mean it's a product
of components with each one having very
very few rules yeah so in that case the
converse assures me that in that bad
situation all the roots are singularity
so I throw in the derivatives also and
and performance new system but I have
reduced the dimensionality
okay
so
yeah so I'm almost out of time and I'm
almost about to end also
to make this deterministic they're gonna
at around the same time
similar ideas came about that's one
paper bite
and another by me which
the essential idea was very similar to
this now notice that
to get this
algorithm going I needed one point on
one of the Curve
so ah
so I was now into the deterministic
conversion
uh
so so I'm given f
I want to sort of factor it
uh so I I take the intersection with the
y-axis with the x axis so I set y equal
to 0
call this as G
and
here what we did was find roots of G
I don't know how to find the roots so
the idea is this go to this ring
s t z
by G of Z
so
in some sense the element red in this
ring is a zero of this
and then just
pretend that this is a field
and and pretend that red is an actual
root of
your polynomial G here and run this
Alpha
and it turns out that if you if you
think about it it will
help you answer these kinds of questions
whether
our polynomial F1 have any absolutely
irreducible factors or not
and that turns out to be good enough for
for the solvability question question
number one
so
it is right here this
then
first offense
attending that
are in the field
foreign
you don't actually get the factors but
it it gives you essentially all
structural properties about the factor
that you may want to know for example
what are the degrees of the factors what
are the extensions in which the what are
the field extensions in which the
various factors like all these
structural properties about the factors
of f you can answer
so I'll just end by making one
remark that so just a question so it
gives you the absolute factorization of
F1 or this algorithm or
so yeah
I I'll tell you a more precise statement
it gives your partial factorization of f
such that in the following cell so
suppose you factor F over the closure
have fun through FS these are the
factors of f over the closure of the of
the base field now you can
collect together all the factors which
have the same degree and the same
splitting through the electric
conjugates so yes which are the
conjugates and multiply all of them out
okay and
so
so this algorithm will give you a
partial factorization which are all
these products of things which are of
the same degree and the same is
deterministic it's deterministic
so much of this generalizes to n equal
to 3 and Beyond
um
yeah but unfortunately
seems that at least the night way that I
was doing in doing it the complexity
becomes
the P exponential with respect to n for
n equal to 3 and Beyond but I suspect
that it is just that uh I was doing a
very sloppy analysis and it can be
improved too
single exponential in them
yeah
so that's it uh any question
are there ones known to be hyped you
know
like t-shirt that exists polynomials
that have Roots at the balance so I'm
not sure because I create a heuristic
calculation and this
so there are some heuristics we suggest
that this error bound should be about
PR D log P root beer so I don't know
whether this d square is straight or not
my suspicion would be that like the year
log P or something like that
okay
when you have just one problem anything
just a surface for example yes
number of points yeah
yeah so this generalizes to three
variables also you can find out whether
it has an absolutely reducible factor or
not oh and so here you can do if you
think about URL algorithm you can find a
distinct degree factors in three
variables
and you can also sort of find the
spreading field
factors
so the bay conjectures placed them all
here is n increasing
uh
not the full conjectures only the bounce
on the number yeah
from all I've seen it's only that these
bounds that we use
I mean you have to know the geometry of
zero set so we really use the binder
but I think
there were maybe a few few cases that
you predict okay
let's see lower bounds if the input
polynomials were sparsely represented or
do you expect that these results will
generalized to sparse polynomials no I
suspect that it was past problem is
things are much more difficult so there
is one result which is known that even
Computing the gcd of two various parts
polynomials is in general NP complete
even a certain words too if you detect
roots for over a prime field if you have
a prime row that's also be hard yes
so in one in one variable sparse is
already hard yes it's just deciding if
you have a really okay so
my question one last time so I guess in
the general case for the number of
rational points the main term is like
huge of the dimension of the zero set
time it's the number of absolutely
Originals components under the error
term is like Q to the D minus a half
times some something do we have any hope
of at least finding that second second
order term
well that's that's somehow intermediate
between the full counting problem in
just this but maybe in some special case
all right for Curves this is already as
hard as the the captain problem but
maybe yeah
sort of like country maybe it's a
problem every situation the degree is
not too large
foreign
any more questions
okay let's thank the Raj again
thank you